foreign
and so the enemy pilot dies the death
that his stupidity deserved if you must
charge towards an aircraft do it at an
angle greetings all I'm Nicholas Morin I
commissioned as an armor officer for M1
tanks and then converted to M3 Bradley's
these days I work as a civilian vehicle
historian primarily for World of Tanks
I'm back again to rate tank battles on
movies and TV and judge how real they
are
[Music]
the rip saw which was basically a
tracked toy for people to drive around
in it looks just like it does in the
movie here it's because it had such
lightweight and such a high powered
weight ratio the thing is incredibly
fast and Incredibly Nimble which of
course attracts the attention of the
military hang on a second we've got this
vehicle that can go anywhere really
really quickly can we do something with
it but the variant that the Army has
been looking at of late is actually a
robotic combat vehicle I believe it's
the rcvm and it's being plugged as the
M5 and on the top much like is shown in
the clip is a remote weapon station
[Music]
foreign
on ice and those don't look like ice
tracks Believe It or Not There is
actually ways you can get more grip on a
tracked vehicle on Ice it's uh anything
from snow chains so I was used in World
War II to these days you can have
grousers that you knock out a few track
pads and you put basically cleats
into the track this thing is going quite
fast doing its various Maneuvers on ice
and that's questionable in this context
oh
[Music]
I can think of no reason except for an
accession to plot why a tank would have
a grappling hook attached to it the
lambo at the point that they connect is
basically underwater and that provides
more drag than this thing can can haul
for those who point for realism the door
came off instead of the lambo getting
pulled out I'm going to be generous I'm
going to give at one point because it
has tracks I'm going to give it one
point because it pulled the door instead
of the whole Lambo so I'm going to give
it a two
foreign
so you will have seen the Americans had
somebody standing on the back firing the
caliber 50. the caliber 50 was
originally put onto American Vehicles as
an anti-aircraft weapon and the reason
that it's on that external mode mounted
the back is that it's a lot easier to
aim upwards if you're standing on the
back deck and then aiming up as opposed
to trying to stick your head out of the
hatch and maybe put it down from the
side and you're not even able to use the
sights
one of the things Sherman was very good
at was showing up when you needed a tank
and they tended not to go around in ones
and twos they tended to go around in
fives and 17. yeah sure on a tank on
tank dual it wasn't necessarily the best
for an infantryman that's under heavy
attack
he doesn't care if the best tank in the
world shows up as long as the tank which
shows up a actually arrives and B is
good enough to deal with whatever the
infantryman's problem is
foreign
s don't actually have any tanks which
was a problem that the Germans had in
World War II is that their industry
simply wasn't up to the levels of
American or Russian so what we have here
are a lot of assault guns and tank
destroyers that looks like martyr there
at least a representation of one a
stunga shots which is an assault gun and
a egg Panther
the egg Panther is the only one that is
the serious threat to an Allied vehicle
[Applause]
why didn't the a panther just sit there
and place its extremely tough frontal
armor to the Sherman that's why you
could do that but then you're probably
now placing your weak flank armor
to the American infantry who are
equipped in the scene with Bazookas
anti-tank rocket launchers the Germans
are now at flanked and so very sensibly
they immediately abandoned the attack
and start falling back this is as good
as you're going to get on Celluloid or
digits if there is ever going to be a 10
for rate a tank battle this is probably
it
the tanks represent Sancho Mall there's
only one that exists in the world it's
at the French national tank Museum in
samur now the cognizantia will look at
the road wheels on that and realize that
the vehicle is based off of a BMP or an
mtlb which are Soviet cold war vehicles
by this point in the war it said we're
talking towards the end of 1918. the
Germans are very familiar with tanks but
you'll still want to shoot them anyway
for a couple of reasons one is if the
tanks are accompanying infantry well
you're going to have an effect on the
Infantry and maybe suppress them to the
point that the tanks are going to
advance on their own secondly the tanks
were not the most robust at the time
there was a problem known as Splash
especially in World War tankers would
actually wear a type chain mail in front
of their face with goggles to stop the
pieces of bullet come in the gaps in the
armor finally it's psychological it
makes you feel a lot better to actually
do something even if it's a gesture of
futility
the early tank guns for World War One
were generally either being converted
artillery pieces or quite often Naval
guns the big problem you're going to
have with getting them close is called
depression so there is a stop as to how
far down the gun will depress and that
determines how close you can get to the
enemy trench before you can have to stop
engaging it
to this stage trench Crossing ability in
terms of meters how many meters of
trench you can cross is still a
Criterion the idea of can you cross it
without collapsing it well that depends
if you want to collapse it or not so
even as late as the Iraq campaigns a
tank would go up to fortified enemy
position
turn on the spot and bury the people
inside and it's one of those unfortunate
realities that
basically tanks have many ways of
killing you and the tracks are one of
them
you think today a hand grenade isn't
going to do very much the tracks on the
sanction model basically for my whole
tractor so they weren't as battle proof
as a modern vehicle would be in fact the
armor on this is so thin that a lot of
heavy bullets they even developed rifle
bullets with an armor-piercing core
could go through these early tanks so
this is an eight and a half maybe nine
that is I could quibble a few things but
it generally gets the concept across
so Rambo has gotten into his
I'm going to call it a t-72 it's not
actually but the helicopter here
represents a hind I think it's actually
a puma but the behind the mi-24 was a
gunship that still actually has a troop
carrying capacity as well as carrying a
lot of rockets and missiles and being
heavily armored it's basically a flying
tank for lack of a better term
[Music]
hang on is he driving or is he going
there's only one tank that I can think
of that is fully combat capable with one
crewman and that is the Swedish strv 103
commonly known as the s-tank the driver
functions as the Gunner as well and this
is why you're supposed to go with
anti-aircraft vehicles in company with
you because their job is to defend you
against their threats
isn't a an attack helicopter a gunship
and it's got missiles on the tips 82
swatters probably that are affected from
several kilometers away and instead he
is firing unguided rockets at the front
Over the Rainbow tank why doesn't he
just fly around the back and shoot the
Rockets into the engine deck or the rear
turret or some place that will actually
cause damage
[Music]
and so the enemy pilot dies the death
that his stupidity deserved officially
if you must charge towards an aircraft
do it at an angle he has to not only aim
for lead but also the change in distance
at the same time whereas if you're
charging straight atom you're
simplifying the problem for the aircraft
that's coming at you he doesn't need to
worry about aiming it has a tank so I'll
give it a one
hold up
the premise of an ambush in an urban
setting by armor is not unheard of but
the idea of armor operating in an urban
setting without infantry support is
normally questionable Panthers are not
well suited for close range fighting
they really would Excel on the Eastern
Front well the steps of Ukraine for
example a nice long lines of fire that
said they can get away with it in this
context because they know that the enemy
is a single tank with no Infantry
you're going through a building again
except this time he's done one thing
right he's got the turret Traverse over
the rear I'd mentioned before you don't
want to go through a building if you can
avoid it in this case I guess they
couldn't because they're getting shot at
and if you are going to go through spin
your turret over and you'll you'll keep
yourself safe
and what you can see here the t3485 has
a very neat Traverse handle so it
performs two functions in this case you
can see he has it in manual mode
cranking around as opposed to Electric
mode which you've simply flipped the
handle line to degrees however maybe the
Gunner just doesn't know this because in
the movie this was a found tank even
myself when I got into a t3485 for the
first time I'm trying to see where is
the second control handle I can't find
it
foreign
this is quite feasible when faced with
the panther this close range t-34 crew
now has a choice it can either run away
or it can attempt to engage now I would
probably agree with the 34 crew on this
for two reasons one the panther was
looking the wrong way entirely and the
other thing is Panthers are not the
easiest thing in the world to kill
unless he can get around the side or
behind them and in this case they're
already behind them
so why not engage but the only thing I
might have done differently was back up
two or three tank links
and aim the gun into the engine deck
that would be a more guaranteed kill
than trying to aim for the turret ring
so the explosion was actually a little
bit faster than what really happened
generally speaking when a tank is hit it
takes a couple of seconds and those are
your couple of seconds that is the
difference between life and death when
you're getting out of a vehicle although
in reality
the net effect difference to the crew is
academic they're they're basically toast
in this context uh I don't know maybe a
seven
the movie is set about the time of the
yemeni Civil War which is actually kind
of still ongoing the film was made in
Morocco hence you have the m60s and the
t-72s so the exact nature of the tanks
that you get in Yemen isn't entirely
there but hey for movie purposes it gets
to point across certainly there are
Western and Eastern tanks in the area
washroom
so what I have here is a vic1 CVC combat
vehicle crewman helmet and the reason
you would want to wear a helmet even if
you're inside the tank is quite simply
you're being thrown around and there's a
lot of sharp pointy things sticking out
at you that as you're being thrown
around you don't want to hurt your head
and of course you also have the dust
goggles
because the tanks are throwing a lot of
dust up at you you don't have a
windshield if you're doing 40 miles an
hour there's still enough wind that
you'll notice so you wear a set of
goggles as well
it's good to see armor actually work so
what has happened there is a round hit
explosive reactive armor so those bricks
that you see what they generally consist
of though this is a gross
oversimplification is a couple of pieces
of metal sandwiching a piece of
explosive that when around hits it it
explodes and disrupt or destabilize it
to the extent that the main armor belt
behind can stop it
what
come back
you got a couple of problems firstly if
the entire turret system is offline then
the tank is Still rocking a little bit
it may not look at much but it's going
to be rocking enough that you cannot hip
shoot a 125 on a on a point target like
a tank like that
secondly he literally it's hip shooting
he's eyeballing it I don't see why he
couldn't still be using this gun sight
he can then pull the trigger himself
um
sandstorms do happen in the 2003
invasion of Iraq there was one that
basically shut down the war for a couple
of days well you're a big problem with
the sandstorm is the air filters so the
sand is going to get into your air
filters and clog them up very quickly
however in this context I don't think
they had a heck of a lot of choice
because being chased by a platoona m60s
they were probably going to die anyway
so why not make for the sandstorm and
hope for the best so I think seven is
probably Fair
I'm not even sure where to start I'm
trying to think of any reasonable
military contacts that this vehicle
could exist in the US Army has vehicle
the m117
which is a derivative of the old lab
100s from Vietnam it's basically a huge
armored 4x4 with a gun turret on the top
for military police use I'm sure they
wouldn't mind something like this
so generally speaking convoys just
because of the nature of Roads you tend
to be in column instead of lying abreast
like in the shot here you have a bit of
a choice depending on how many vehicles
you have is how far apart you want the
vehicles to be because the idea is that
your lead vehicle is going to be
sufficiently far in front of whatever it
is that you're protecting the main body
of the Convoy so with only three
vehicles you're kind of limited as to
what you can do but your typical is
going to be maybe two up front than the
main asset and then one bringing up the
rear
funds are not common but they are a
thing you sometimes find the mounted as
experiments on tanks as well but they're
they're basically a waste of space and
weight so you don't see them on tanks
in terms of the missile launcher
yeah missile launchers on armored cars
are a thing this particular elevating
out of the 4x4 is probably closer to a
brdm anti-tank system but that's
actually for anti-armor purposes not
anti-aircraft
but hey we're I guess when you're
dealing with Batman Anything Goes I I
got nothing the zero sorry that no she's
fired dark destroyed
the Germans appear to be equipped with
pack 40s it was a very good anti-tank on
7.5 centimeter caliber definitely a
valid threat against an M4
that was a doctrinal fire command now
the reason I know this is they actually
sent me the script for filming it but
that is basically alert Target and uh
command of execution in abbreviated fire
command the fire commands back in World
War II weren't quite as regimented as
they are today but the fundamentals are
actually still the same
you have an argument do you want to
advance over open ground as a whole
platoon or do you want to Bound in
sections in this case because of the
amount of infantry that they're trying
to provide cover for I can see perhaps
why they went as a full platoon online
but also it's a very very open long
field so maybe it was necessary for the
entire platoon to advance online simply
so that they could see the target
there's another gun who's got eyes on it
somebody's going to ask how can a pac-40
Miss at such short range you will be
surprised what stress is going to do to
you so there have been studies and the
reputation at the 88 is such that it
doesn't miss in reality they're firing
20 rounds to get a single kill because
the stress of combat is such that it is
not calm and collected on a Gunnery
Range when you're doing scientific
testing it's oh God I'm about to die
let's light them up let's go
now that scene is basically why I became
a tanker a line of Tanks every machine
gun going a single tank is considered to
have Firepower more or less equivalent
to an infantry platoon because you have
the heavy machine gun up top you got a
coax machine gun you've got a bow
machine gun and oh by the way you've got
a cannon that is a lot of Firepower from
a single vehicle you can imagine this
sheer suppression and psychological
effect that comes of this let alone the
lethal effects I know there are folks
that didn't like that I gave the last
Fury a nine but I'm giving this one a
nine as well
can't get elevation he knows it
so this was an actual problem in
Afghanistan and it's a mountainous
country is that their tanks which were
designed really for open Warfare on the
plains of Germany can't Elevate high
enough so what the Soviets ended up
doing was they developed a variant of
the zsu-234 anti-aircraft gun the shulka
called the the afghanit so they would
use those in conjunction with the tanks
to provide that close range high
elevation security that dascal here is
having a problem with
the actual effect of hitting the gun
tube is not going to be the paddling
like you see here that's for visual
effects whether you're actually going to
get it's a very small hole
that goes through the gun tube but it's
still plenty bad enough that you you've
disabled the gun
thank you
the grenade will not have separated the
tracks so I must conclude it was the
Rocks but it's not impossible for Rocky
terrain and maybe a less experienced
driver to angle his track in such a way
when he's turning that he gets rocks
Caught In Between the Wheels and the
tracks and snaps the track pin and that
throws your track and loses it this
scene is probably a seven to an eight so
out of the clips that we saw today if I
had to recommend one and one only to
watch I'd probably go with bander
Brothers which is more of an infantry
related show but tanks work with the
Infantry and it's always good to
understand it well thanks for watching I
hope you found it interesting and
informative if you want more of the same
sort of thing add one form Travis Wright
and click the video in that box